hemos hecho la evaluación de que el Coby
19 puede caracterizarse como una
pandemia
este anuncio cambió la historia de la
humanidad comenzaba así un periodo de
crisis y medidas drásticas
todos enfrentamos una amenaza común el
coronavirus Kobe 19 la declaración de
pandemia de hoy es un llamado a la
acción para todos en todas partes
también es un llamado a la
responsabilidad y solidaridad
los confinamientos una de las medidas
para evitar la propagación convirtieron
a las principales urbes en ciudades
fantasma una calma solo rota por
muestras de Patriotismo como en Italia
una de las naciones más afectadas por la
enfermedad
[Música]
pero no todos en el mundo estuvieron
conformes en China la política cero
covid provocó el descontento de la
población
[Aplausos]
Al otro lado del mundo algunos
mandatarios se mostraron escépticos por
los encierros
no vamos a destruir nuestro país tenemos
que regresar porque ya sabes en cierto
punto perderás más personas de esta
manera por todos los problemas causados
que con lo que estamos haciendo
según la universidad John Hopkins hasta
el mes de marzo de 2023 se
contabilizaron unos 676 millones
609.955 casos de estos pacientes 6
millones
881.955 fallecieron un cambio importante
en la estrategia de combate al virus
resultaron ser las vacunas hasta la
misma fecha se han inoculado más de
13.300 millones de personas sin embargo
a pesar de que las restricciones han
venido disminuyendo considerablemente el
covid sigue siendo considerado una
emergencia sanitaria mundial